love the marvelous missus Mazal it is a
tremendous show it deserves every
accolade it receives and today it
received another one SAG nominations are
out outstanding performance by an
ensemble in a comedy series of which
Kevin is a part they won the award last
year they will be able to defend their
SAG Award ensemble title and it is just
all that in a biscuit it's amazing and
we'll have a Kevin out on the show he is
wearing 49ers paraphernalia all right I
don't know if he's aware that Madison
Bumgarner could be a Dodger by the end
of the week we'll ask him battle but we
turn to the phone lines right now and
find one of the best in his business as
well MLB insider for ESPN espn.com ESPN
The Magazine Jeff Passan joining us here
on the Rich Eisen show how are you Jeff
I'm so glad you brought up the marvelous
mrs. Maysles as I was watching the new
season on my flight out here to the
Winter Meetings in San Diego yep and
came to the realization that Kevin
Pollak's character is my favorite
character on telepath well he's in our
green room and just heard that Jeff he
is he is bad I am now granted this is
like super wheelhouse for me but anyone
who grew up in a Jewish family knows
exactly who that is yeah anybody who
like we just know we all have that uncle
who was the worst I know and he is the
worst and and and and anybody who could
play somebody named mrs. Mazal as well
as as she does and her last name is
really Brosnahan in real life I think
she deserves every award I know it
really is okay let's get to the show
that Major League Baseball is putting on
why now Jeff after after it darn near
went into Valentine's Day last year for
everybody why now what's happening like
you know I I think there are a couple of
different factors number one I Gerrit
Cole I'm sorry it's just better than
just about anyone who's been a free
agent over the last half decade
I mean he's I I have been calling him
the best free agent pitcher in baseball
history and and people are pushing back
on
you Brandi Johnson with a free agent
after he went to Houston and killed it
Greg Maddux for the free agent you know
the year after he want to say young and
Buzzard those are reasonable fare
arguments but what Gerrit Cole has is
he's got age on a side at 29 years old
he's got better stuff than those guys
did you know Randy Johnson great
fastball great slider Gary Cole's got
four plus two plus plus pitches he's got
the leadership element he's got the
intelligence he's got everything humanly
possible going for him and he's coming
off of an incredible year and it's the
reason that the New York Yankees and Los
Angeles Dodgers who are arguably the two
best run teams in baseball right now
we're fighting each other for him and
it's the reason he got 324 million
dollars rich when the previous record
coming into the Winter Meetings for a
pitcher was almost 50% less David Price
at 217 million dollars so it has been an
incredible turn event at the top of
market but beyond that you had the
Cincinnati's of the world trying to
compete you know the Chicago White Sox
who haven't spent forever
trying to compete and giving us money
grand off 73 million dollars you've got
the Philadelphia Phillies giving Zack
wheeler 118 million dollars you've got
competitiveness and shock of shocks when
teams want to win they will go out and
spend money to do it so you just
unloaded a lot right there let me let me
follow up on some of these things so it
was did the Yankees bid the highest I
mean is that what happened that they
just ended up they ended up giving the
most money and that's why they got him
no I think they got him because they're
the New York Yankees and because they
gave the most money it was a fortuitous
combination I think he wanted to go to
the Yankees and I think that the Dodgers
and angels made representative bids he
would have gotten three hundred million
dollars from all three of the teams but
when it was all said and done
Jericho wanted to be Hankey and you know
I love watching narratives die and the
idea that he was only going to be on the
west coast it's it is just such a crock
of crap never believed that like these
guys want two things and I'm saying all
of them do they want money and they want
to win and they want money because money
is awesome and they want to win because
they're competitors and they would not
be what they are if they weren't that
said Pittsburgh in Houston is not New
York City and you know Cole obviously
does he have the stuff of if he does
come up with let's say a non quality
start against the Red Sox that he
follows up with a non quality start in
his first trip back to Minute Maid and
then strolls into Yankee Stadium and has
another does he have that quality to
just brush all that off and and dominate
anyway not only rich does he have this
stuff I think he is personality wise one
of the rare guys who actually could get
even better when he goes to New York I
think he craves the moment I think he
rides on pressure I think he loves being
in that spot where you need to be the
guy he has been saddled with first five
years of his career in Pittsburgh and he
went to Houston and was unleashed and
was a new man and was with a team that
was winning at a franchise that that was
among the best in baseball and will
continue to be the Astros among the best
in baseball and that opened something up
in him and I think he's only gonna get
more in New York because Brian Cashman
and how Steinbrenner have put together a
juggernaut and in terms of that I mean
the the young studs are all several
years away from having to get paid free
agency right judge and Sanchez and
tourists the labor Torres yeah I mean
they you know they're gonna be cheap for
the next couple years we're in the
Yankees are gonna run into problems
though is you have two guys who are
essentially getting paid 650 million
dollars combined on their contract and
Giancarlo Stanton and Gerrit Cole and
Stanton
you know exceedingly unlikely to opt out
after next season so he's gonna be owed
you know well over 200 million dollars
excuse me I think it's a hundred ninety
million dollars for the last seven years
of that dealing Cole's got three 25:36 a
year coming for each of the next nine
seasons it's a pretty big chunk of
change there for the Yankee so they're
gonna have to be creative to keep this
core together but they can't look at
that right now they have to look at this
small window you can't look in five-year
increments anymore it's almost like a
two-year increment that you have to say
okay if we have the opportunity to win
now let's go out and do it it's like
football with a with a with a rookie
quarterback that blossoms quickly before
they have to pay them in a big fat
contract that saddles a cap you better
win your championship in the first five
years it's exactly like that
a hundred percent correct years talking
about that in the lobby last night how
it's what the Angels have in Shohei
Otani you know I had to pay him only a
couple million dollars to come over
where if you were on the open market he
probably would have gotten 200 million
you have to take advantage of that time
when players are not getting paid market
value and that's what the Yankees are
doing right now and giving Derek all
this money all right Jeff Passan here on
from ESPN on the Rich Eisen show
what's the Rendon market looking like
right now you know
third base market rich is just in such
quicksand right now because you have a
finite number of teams who want need
elite level third baseman and you've got
a bunch of them who are actually
available you can go out and get ran
down for you know 250 million dollars
you can go out and get Josh Donaldson
right now the market for him is 3 times
25 he's looking for a fourth year you
can go out and trade for Chris Bryant
and you could potentially probably not
but potentially go out trade for Nolan
Arenado as well the Rockies are
listening on
at this point so you've got four
all-star caliber third baseman who are
available and if you're the you're the
Los Angeles Dodgers for example and
Justin Turner is willing to move over to
first base to do the Texas Rangers and
you need a big name to move into your
new ballpark if you're the Atlanta
Braves and I have some salary room to
spend that money if you're the
Washington Nationals who want to replace
run down there are a lot of options out
there and I think once one of them goes
all of them are going to go but
everyone's just waiting for one team to
make the first move could the Nats be
still in the Rendon market or that's
just the way that ship is sail because
of the Strasburg contract I mean it's
gonna be a really burdensome thing
financially for them to do that because
give Strasburg 245 million you get ran
down 250 I mean that's a half billion
dollar off season right there and I know
they won the World Series and that's an
awfully awfully nice thing to do but is
that a half billion dollar bump for them
now probably not and then a couple last
one for year Jeff Passan Bumgarner is a
Dodger is that is that a possibility for
them to turn to their longtime nemesis
as a we couldn't get Cole let's turn to
Madison is that possible Marc it's
really good right now you know because
of the financial level that he's at
which is going to be around a hundred
million dollars give or take ten million
he's got suitors not just the Dodgers
but the twins are in on him the the Blue
Jays the white sox could be in on him
the Braves the Rangers I mean any number
of teams could go out and since that
could go out and get him as that guy who
can be toward the top of your rotation
even if it's not going to be a Gerrit
Cole er Stephen Strasburg
all right and then last one for you Jeff
you've been you
said use a lot of talking going on in
the in the lobby there my my sound
engineer Mike Dell Tufo one rarely pays
attention anything that comes out of my
mouth or says anything germane to the
sports conversation just said out of the
blue that this was a the Col the Yankees
wanted in their stocking is that phrase
that you've heard anywhere do you think
he might have picked that out he swears
he came up with that himself Jeff Scott
Boras dad jump special right there and
you should be embarrassing your parody
okay Jeff thank you appreciate the time
brother I know you're busy thanks for
calling him take care that's Jeff Passan
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app